Now let's discuss the first
major Internet worm,
also called the Morris worm
after its creator Robert Morris.
Here's how the worm worked.
When the worm runs on a system,
it looks for
other systems on the Internet
that it can spread to.
For example, these systems have
some security vulnerabilities
that the worm can exploit.
And then by exploiting
these vulnerabilities,
the worm can infect these systems.
In other words, it can lure itself to
these systems and that's how it spread.
Once the worm got on a system,
it also employed a number of tricks in
order to keep himself from detectable.
According to each creator,
the Internet worm was made as part
of an experiment to measure
the size of the internet.
For example, by measuring how many
computers are connected together.
However, there was a programming
error in the code.
That is the worm would infect
a computer regardless,
whether the computer had been infected
already one out of seven times.
This proved to be too aggressive.
And as a result,
many computers get infected repeatedly.
That is on these computers, there
are many instances of the same worm
running resulting in
resource exhaustions.
And that's really how
the Internet worm was discovered,
because the system admins find out
that their servers were overloaded.
As a response, many system admins
disconnect their servers from
the internet in order to stop
the spread of the Internet worm.
But since many servers
were disconnected,
the Internet was disrupted as well.
When the Internet worm identified
the next target to infect, it looked for
several security flaws that
it knew how to exploit.
These include systems
with guessable passwords,
systems running the fingerd program that
had a buffer overflow vulnerability.
Systems running a sendmail program that
has a trapdoor, which means that by
supplying some special input commands,
one can gain access to these systems.
When the security flaws were exploited,
the Internet worm can gain
access to a target system.
It then will load a small piece of
code called the bootstrap loader on to
a target machine and this loader will
then fetch the rest of the worm code.
It even used password based
authentication to make sure that only
the bootstrap loader of the worm can
load the rest of the code of the worm.
The Internet worm also employed
a number of tricks to hide itself.
For example,
the worm code is loaded into the memory.
It is encrypted and
decrypted when necessary and
the original file is removed
from the hard drive, so
that the user will not be
able to see the worm program.
The worm even periodically change
its process name and process ID, so
that even when a system admin looks at
what programs are running on the server,
he cannot easily discover
the Internet worm.
The Internet worm resulted in major
deception to the Internet, because many
servers were infected and had to
be disconnected from the Internet.
So what lessons did we learn?
The first lesson we learned
was that we need to perform
security scanning and patching.
The Internet worm was able to infect so
many servers,
because these servers
had security flaws.
Further, most of these flaws
were not only well-known, but
also had security patches or
fixes available.
Therefore, if we scan and
patch computers on the Internet
that have security flaws,
then we can reduce the chances that
they will be infected by malware.
The second lesson is that
we need to have a fast and
coordinated response to a major security
incident such as the Internet worm.
And because of the Internet worm, the US
government established the computer
emergency response team or
CERT for short.
Nowadays, CERT is
usually responsible for
issuing alerts about security for
flaws and recommendations about patches.